integration heißt nicht beliebig
nebeneinander her und jeder kann machen
was er mag wir beschreiben integration
als gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe das
ist ein unterschied
[Musik]
sie arbeiten in hamburg in der
flüchtlings ambulanz waren auch 2015
sehr engagiert haben vielen menschen die
damals ins land gekommen sind geholfen
dabei fuß zu fassen was ist denn jetzt
aus ihrer sicht nach 56 jahren das
größte integrationshindernis noch ich
glaube das größte integrationshindernis
ist dass wir über einen integrations
griff sprechen der auf einseitiger
anpassungen basiert das heißt wir
vergessen dass integration auch bedeutet
sich auf augenhöhe zu begegnen das heißt
wenn wir wie sie zb herr herrmann über
diejenigen sprechen die aus bestimmten
ländern kommen und diese länder mit
bestimmten stigmatisierung
zusammenhängen dann habe ich als eine
person die mich integrieren soll ein
problem das heißt ich sehe vorteile ich
die stereotypisierung auf den seiten auf
beiden seiten und dann fehlt mir die
begegnung auf augenhöhe minister einsatz
gerade aus dem filmbeitrag
hängengeblieben pochen auf bringschuld
verletzt mich sagen sie inwiefern mich
verletzt der begriff bringschuld weil er
ebenso ein unebenes verhältnis herstellt
das heißt ich als jemand der
beispielsweise hier geboren worden ist
ich habe gar keine andere heimat kein
anderes zuhause und trotzdem begegnet
mir seit ich im kindergarten bin seit
ich in der grundschule gewesen bin
im studium immer die ansicht dass
menschen mit migrationsgeschichte mehr
leisten müssen
und das verursacht nicht nur stress das
verursacht trug und es verursacht eben
auch wut weil man sieht wie ungerecht
bestimmte systeme sind und deswegen
glaube ich eben wir können nicht über
integration sprechen ohne über die
ganzen hindernisse auf dem weg zur
integration zu sprechen
sehr klar estate eine klare haltung gibt
mir das mal auf die andere seite der
unterlagen hindernisse auf dem weg zur
integration vorurteile stereotype das
wird hier auf der seite derjenigen die
sagen man muss als zugewandert hat
vielleicht auch etwas mitbringen
wahrscheinlich anders gesehen
paulina hary aber herzlichen herzlich
willkommen
aus scheu war wir haben sie gerade eben
im film schon kennengelernt ein wenig
ich mich hat sehr beeindruckt dass sie
gesagt haben mein weg war nicht einfach
das war schon ganz schön schwierig sie
sind ihnen aber gegangen trotzdem sagen
sie
jeder ist selbst dafür verantwortlich
willkommen zu sein warum diese
zurückhaltende haltung ja weil ich ja
tatsächlich diesen schwierigen weg
gegangen bin und auch für mich
festgestellt habe dass auch ich zum
beispiel in dieser starken opferhaltung
war die mich dann wirklich in dem weg
der integration sehr stark behindert hat
und als ich das für mich verstanden habe
habe ich gemerkt okay ich als migranten
muss auch das wollen hier voranzukommen
sprich dass ich die sprache lerne so
schnell wie möglich den kontakt zu den
einheimischen zu suchen so schnell wie
möglich und mich wirklich mit den grund
mit dem grundgesetz auseinandersetzen
themen wie sexuelle vielfalt
meinungsfreiheit gleichberechtigung
zwischen männern und frauen thema
antisemitismus und ich mich als
migranten immer fragen muss
identifiziere ich mich mit diesen werten
wenn ja wunderbar wenn nicht dann soll
ich mir die frage stehen ob dieses land
tatsächlich auch das richtige land für
mich ist wo ich mich auch wohl fühlen
kann
das ist eine sehr klare ansage von
jemandem der den weg gegangen ist ja und
wir wollen genau dieses stichwort
aufnehmen grundwerte wir haben eben
schon mal ihr erstes zwiegespräch dazu
gehört und wollen das jetzt auch konkret
eben vor dem hintergrund der
bundestagswahl uns noch mal genauer
anschauen und in ihr wahlprogramm von
cdu und csu hermann dasteht
voraussetzung für eine gelingende
integration ist ein bekenntnis zu
deutschlands grundlegenden werten und
normen sams erheben auch schon mal
angerissen aber was heißt das konkret
pünktlichkeit ordentlichkeit dass er
wahrscheinlich nicht damit gemeint ich
habe die grundwerte ja aus dem
grundgesetz gerade angesprochen da steht
nichts von pünktlichkeit und
ordentlichkeit aber der gehört zb die
religionsfreiheit dazu und das bedeutet
automatisch die toleranz gegenüber
andersgläubigen
da hat mir gar nicht gefallen wie viele
menschen mit migrationshintergrund vor
einigen wochen wirklich mit
antisemitischen antijüdischen thesen auf
deutschlands straßen unterwegs waren
das ist zum beispiel ein ganz
wesentlicher grundwert unserer
verfassung religionsfreiheit die
toleranz die der respekt davor ich habe
meinen glauben aber ich muss respekt
haben davon dass jemand andere jemand
was anderes glaubt in der tat das thema
gleichberechtigung von mann und frau
all diese grundwerte die in unserer
verfassung stehen darum geht es und die
müssen wir in der tat einfordern es geht
nicht um bringschuld oder holschuld
diese worte mag ich in der tat auch
überhaupt nicht aber es geht darum dass
dieses integration integration heißt
nicht beliebig nebeneinander her und
jeder kann machen was er mag
wir haben sind ein sehr sehr
freiheitliche gesellschaft aber das
wenige muss man ja sagen was wirklich
verbindlich für unsere eigene
bevölkerung festgeschrieben ist auch an
grundwerten in unserer gesellschaft wie
wir zusammenleben wollen
das gilt auch für jeden der neu in unser
land kommen das heißt nämlich frau
katharina mit zur einem direkt antworten
grundgesetz als rahmen sozusagen gehen
sie damit natürlich gehe ich damit aber
da gehen nach andere menschen im nation
geschichte mit ich finde das ist gar
keine kategorie person mit oder ohne
migrationshintergrund und dann kann man
entscheiden ob sich jemand an das
grundgesetz an unsere verfassung hält an
unsere verfassung halten uns alle und
haben wir uns alle zu halten
aber es gibt menschen ohne
migrationshintergrund die sich daran
nicht halten und es gibt menschen mit
halten das ist jenseits von
nationalitäten das ist jenseits von
religion
das ist jenseits von diesen äußeren
kategorien fest zu machen und deswegen
gehe ich da nicht mit einher dass es
eben bestimmte menschen gibt die sich
eher nicht ans grundgesetz halten das
ist faktisch nicht haltbar und ich
glaube ja aber bei sehr vage die frage
war was sie von jemand erwartet dass sie
auf dauer in unser land integrieren will
und da habe ich das genannt in der rat
erwarte ich dann will ich von jedem
deutschen mitbürger auch dass er die
grundwerte unserer verfassung
respektieren
bekämpfe ich jeden antisemitismus wenn
er von einem rechtsradikalen bekommen
aber ich bekämpfe antisemitismus auch
wenn er zb
von einem neuen islamistisch
zugewanderten kommt und sohn aber das
problem dass sie differenziere ich die
menschen nicht daran ob sie jetzt
migration hin das problem dass viele nur
haben ist dass das eben nicht gesagt
wurde und dieses narrativ was
aufrechterhalten wird dass vor allem
menschen mit migrationshintergrund sich
an das grundgesetz zu halten haben ist
glaube ich ein ganz gefährliches weil
diese sich genauso wie menschen ohne
migrationshintergrund an das grundgesetz
halten und zu halten haben
und ich glaube um auf ihre frage wieder
zurückzukommen ich finde es eben
schwierig werden wir von denen und uns
sprechen und hier eben eine grenze
einbringen ich glaube natürlich haben
uns alle an das grundgesetz zu halten
und ich denke wir wissen dass das mit
und ohne migrationshintergrund geld
wir wollen in dieser sendung auch immer
wieder in die wahlprogramme schauen denn
wir sind im wahljahr und sie
beschäftigen sich auch mit blick auf die
wahl auf mit dem thema integration
leisten bei ihnen in der bei der spd im
wahlprogramm steht drin integration ist
eine permanente gesellschaftliche wie
auch staatliche aufgabe das ist jetzt
relativ allgemein gefasst stimmen sie
den herrn herrmann und frauchen war auch
zu dir sagen am ende muss es aber doch
auf ganz bestimmte werte rauslaufen und
da müssen sich alle an schließen wenn
sie können aber in den beiden zitaten
die sie jetzt aus den beiden
wahlprogrammen zitiert haben ja schon
den unterschied erkennen
dort ist integration als eine leistung
dessen der sich integrieren soll der
also in unsere gesellschaft hinein will
oder die beschrieben und wir beschreiben
integration als gesamtgesellschaftliche
aufgabe das ist ein unterschied aber das
ziel ist vorgegeben oder ist das bei
ihnen auch völlig offen jeder kann sich
so ein bisschen integra ziel ist dass
wir als menschen mit mit einer mit ner
aber auf dem selbstverständlich auf dem
boden unserer
freiheitlich-demokratischen grundordnung
und unserer werte gut zusammenleben und
auch im zusammenhalt in vielfalt und
zusammenhalt natürlich das ist aber
nicht eine ständige arbeit die wir als
gesellschaft zu leisten haben und die
natürlich auch menschen zu leisten haben
die ohne migrationsgeschichte schon sehr
sehr lange hier leben mit ihren familien
wir haben ständig daran zu arbeiten dass
wir um wir entwickeln unsere werte ja
auch weiter ja und da müssen wir alle
auch daran teilhaben darf ich einiges
für die noch zu recht
ja und wir betonen in der tat jeder der
sich hier integrieren will muss seinen
eigenen beitrag leisten aber es wird
sehr wohl generell in unserer politik
und auch in unser programm auch gleich
das ist auch natürlich eine aufgabe die
gesellschaft es ist auch eine aufgabe
des staates zu sprechen wir von fördern
und fordern
der staat tut sehr viel um diese
integration zu unterstützen
aber es braucht genauso wie angesprochen
und natürlich auch den eigenen beitrag
derer die sich integrieren wollen
malama vielleicht ganz kurz wenn ich
mich an das erinnern was sie eben zu
beginn der sendung gesagt haben jetzt
zum beispiel fordern und fördern hören
geht der puls in die höhe oder gehen sie
damit sind auch da wirklich ich mich
fühle weil es ist letztlich so also ich
weiß noch nicht wer genau damit gemeint
ist halt nur wenn ich mich also wenn ich
jetzt nur für mich sprechen
ich kann für mich nicht einfach nur
sagen nur weil ich will dann werde ich
diese und jene dinge schaffen weil das
ignoriert komplett den strukturellen
rassismus dem man auch und ich oder die
strukturellen hören die du je nur mal in
diesem land entgegen kommt also sei es
wohnungsmarkt suche jobsuche oder was
auch mal wer den falschen namen hast da
kannst du als auch für das grundgesetz
stören wie du willst du bekommst nichts
so also und es geht auch gar nicht um
eine opferhaltung da würden wir schon
lange drüber hinweg wir machen unseren
teil und wir haben unsere arbeit wir
haben unsere firmen gegründet was auch
immer aber trotzdem sind wir immer noch
mit diesem strukturellen problem die wir
begegnen und ich rede nicht von leuten
die migrationsgeschichte haben die auf
die straße gehen und was aber sich das
könnte ich genauso von von deutsch
deutsch super deutschen was auch immer
sagen die jeden marzahn lichtenberg oder
was sonst alles wollen in diesem bezirk
ich als kind tatsächlich nicht gehen
konnte durfte sollte was auch immer weil
ich aufpassen muss dass ich dort nicht
zusammen geschlagen werde so also ich
bin in einer kindheit gut geworden in
ostberlin wo ist halt zum vatertag hieß
es geht nicht raus der laufen betroffene
männer herum und die könnten sich
verprügeln das waren aus berlin oder zum
fußball spielen wo ich halt als affe
beschimpft wurde und mit affen
geräuschen vom platz gejagt wurde
es geht nicht um eine abwehrhaltung
sorry er gehe ich überhaupt nicht mit
das habe ich auch in diese bin ich auch
nie rein gegangen ich habe meinen teil
getan aber du wirst hier strukturell
daran gehindert die zwei perspektiven
von beiden seiten sind grundsätzlich
glaube ich jetzt sehr gut klar geworden
vielen dank für diesen input jetzt
gucken wir mal konkret welche probleme
gibt es konkret welche konflikte aber
auch welche lösungsansätze
ja wir haben schon gehört dass das ganz
viele emotionen ausgelöst auch bei
menschen die wirklich jeden tag
tatsächlich direkt betroffen sind und
ihr leben lang damit zu tun haben ich
nehme diesen eindruck mal mit rüber auf
die seite derjenigen die sagen trotzdem
bleibt es dabei wir haben probleme mit
integration nicht mit jedem aber doch an
manchen stellen wir begrüßen jetzt heute
abend hier bei unserer knispel
oberstaatsanwalt in berlin herzlich
willkommen in der sendung
max ist in ihrer arbeit haben sie
täglich in kontakt mit der polizei sie
haben leider auch täglichen kontakt mit
den menschen die mit dem gesetz in
konflikt geraten und dazu gehören an
manchen stellen überdurchschnittlich
viele menschen mit migrationshintergrund
oder zugewanderte sehen sie das
eigentlich als problem der integration
wir stehen am ende der gescheiterten
integration das heißt die personen mit
denen die strafjustiz zu tun hat sind
letztlich in der integration gescheitert
und er habe man alles völlig zutreffend
angesprochen und ich will mich los
machen von den begriffen der bringschuld
oder nicht das ist ein geben und nehmen
aber dazu gehört auch dass die menschen
dieser gesellschaft leben wollen unsere
werte christlich und andere werte auch
die aus dem grundgesetz übernehmen und
das was herr mann ansprach gleichheit
von mann und frau religionsfreiheit
genau das sind die probleme wo wir
feststellen dass in vielen kreisen derer
die nach deutschland gekommen sind genau
diese werte nicht akzeptiert werden und
mir vierte dieser ganzen diskussion die
ehrlichkeit wir kommen mit großen
begriffen und forderungen nicht weiter
natürlich muss unsere gesellschaft auch
auf menschen die hier integriert werden
wollen zu gehen aber das heißt auch dass
natürlich diejenigen nach deutschland
kommen sich diesen regelungen anpassen
müssen in weiten teilen und wir müssen
auch feststellen wenn wir differenzieren
zwischen denen die nach deutschland
einwandern
das verändert hat sehr große
unterschiede feststellen bei denen die
deutsch lernen wollen die unsere werte
übernehmen wollen und die auch bereit
sind beispielsweise gleichheit von mann
und frau zu gewährleisten
und wir möchten ungern menschen in
deutschland haben und da werden wir uns
auch nicht als gesellschaft auf
diejenigen zu bewegen müssen
die beispielsweise von christen als
ungläubigen reden die antisemitismus
offen zur schau tragen wo wir an da die
kollegen aus hamburg selbstverständlich
recht natürlich gehört dass auch bei
deutschen verfolgt aber menschen die
dieses zu dieser gesellschaft hin zu
gehören wollen die müssen diese werte
verinnerlichen und die dürfen auch
beispielsweise nicht eigene communitys
führen wo sie nicht aber die deutsche
sprache lernen müssen wo sie eigene
fernsehsender haben wo sie eigene
geschäfte haben und sich offenkundig von
dieser gesellschaft die bereit sie
aufzunehmen abwenden
wir haben sie schon einige der probleme
angesprochen die auch auf diskutiert
werden parallelgesellschaften zum
beispiel aber eben auch organisierte
kriminalität erschienen da schon mit
durch sie haben gerade ganz kategorisch
gesagt das ist gescheiterte integration
da steht ja schon ein
richter runter haben sie denn eigentlich
noch erwartungen an die politik wo kann
man da noch ansetzen erwartungen haben
wir viele ob die erfüllt werden das wird
man sehen da sind tatsächlich skeptisch
ich habe auch nur von denen gesprochen
die bei der strafjustiz anlanden
dort ist die integration gescheitert ich
würde mir niemals anmaßen über
integration insgesamt als gescheiterten
projekt zu reden aber die die mit der
strafjustiz zu tun haben die sind aus
und dessen und sie zeigen uns auch dass
ganz viele bemühungen unternommen worden
sind vielschichtig lange bevor die
strafjustiz überhaupt zum zuge kommt es
gibt möglichkeiten jugend wird
unterstütze es gibt auch andere
möglichkeiten familien werden begleitet
ihn wären möglichkeiten geboten
ihnen werden auch staatliche hilfen zu
teil auch finanzieller art nur die muss
man auch annehmen und es gibt viele
bevölkerungskreise die zugewandert sind
nach deutschland die das auch tun mit
denen die strafjustiz so gut wie gar
keine oder ganz wenige probleme hat und
das kann nicht gottgegeben oder
genetisch bedingt sein dass es da große
unterschiede gibt
[Musik]